[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et tous bienvenue pour
cette première table ronde consacrée à
la démocratie à la citoyenneté autour du
thème comment a réveillé la conscience
civique
donc je m'appelle fabien robert je vais
avoir le plaisir d'animer cette table
ronde avec plusieurs invités
je vais tout d'abord commencer par les
présenter avant de dire un petit mot du
sujet et bien sûr de leurs assez la
parole
je voudrais tout d'abord saluer laurence
parent qui est députée européenne qui
nous fait le plaisir d'être avec nous
bonjour salue également gagnent wehrling
ambassadeur délégué à l'environnement
conseiller régional d'ile-de-france
bonjour yable je ne serai bien voudrais
saluer
richard ramos député du loiret
secrétaire général adjoint du modem dont
on voit dans son environnement qu'il
nous fait le plaisir d'être avec nous
malgré quelques sujets de santé
merci richard je voudrais également
saluer erwan balanant député du
finistère qui est avec nous pour cette
table ronde à nathalie à viesly masse va
nous rejoindre dans les minutes qui
viennent donc nous allons aborder
ensemble pendant une petite heure ce
thème comment réveiller la conscience
civique et avant de donner la parole à
laurence parent je voudrais dire
quelques mots bref du sujet il nous
apparaît assez évident je crois aux uns
et aux autres que il ya un
endormissement de la conscience civique
suivant les périodes suivant les
générations suivant les élections
peut-être aussi qui se caractérise on y
pense tous bien sûr par la montée de
l'abstention qui nous a d'ailleurs
peut-être particulièrement frappés lors
des dernières élections locales au point
peut-être d'ailleurs de fossés ou en
tout cas de provoquer des résultats
surprenants mais la conscience civique
ce n'est pas que le vote
bien sûr c'est aussi l'engagement plus
largement et on peut
également regretter ou en tout cas
s'interroger sur la force aussi des
mouvements politiques aujourd'hui et des
mouvements citoyens qui sans doute pour
certains peinent à recruter ou à
développer des forces vives
bref on parle souvent de crise de la
démocratie représentative et s'est
étroitement lié à cette question de la
de la conscience civique
parallèlement à cela il y a des raisons
d'espérer parce qu'il ya une multitude
de d'éléments positifs on a en tête
aussi les mobilisations citoyennes très
forte les marches
par exemple pour le climat notamment
chez les plus jeunes qui se mobilise
fortement les mobilisations parfois
anticonformiste non institutionnalisée
parfois dérangeante mais qui sont
réelles on a aussi en tête des
participations à certaines élections qui
nous ont agréablement surprise je pense
évidemment à la dernière élection
européenne on repart avec laurence bien
peut-être un étranger à l'élection
américaine donc il y a aussi des raisons
d'espérer et d'une certaine manière une
vraie mobilisation de nos concitoyens en
fonction des sujets et en fonction des
époques
alors pour tout de suite passé la parole
à laurent sfar 1 laurence tu as été élue
députée européenne lors d'une élection
où tout le monde a annoncé une
abstention très forte et elle l'a été
beaucoup moins que prévu
comment tu expliques ce phénomène et
qu'elle regarde tu portes sur se
réveille aujourd'hui nécessaire de la
conscience civique
merci fabien
en effet alors moi ce que je voudrais
dire c'est qu'en effet je pense qu'il
n'y a pas de meilleur support à la
démocratie que des élections mais qu en
effet comme ça a été décrit par cette
introduction on a un problème pour les
réconforter et à ce titre les élections
européennes sont un cas d'école parce
que depuis des échéances et des
échéances et l'élection mal aimé des
citoyens celle où on attend toujours
beaucoup de l'abstention et en 2019
il ya eu en france et dans les autres
pays européens
une participation inédite en france près
de +2 8% par rapport à 2014 c'est très
intéressant parce que si on regarde dans
les faits qu'est ce qui se passait au
même moment
dans la société et bien en france on
était en plein grand débat national pour
les gilet jaune
je pense que c'est très intéressant de
s'arrêter sur ce point parce que le
mouvement s'était déclenchée avait été
très évolutif et puis ce grand débat
était arrivé où partout dans notre pays
des débats ont été organisés et
médiatisée par les élus locaux
je pense que ça c'est très important il
faut s'en rappeler parce que le débat il
a commencé à mûrir à maturer et et à
éveiller et à éveiller la conscience sur
la démocratie est sans doute à la
valoriser deuxième sujet ça a été dit
aussi on était sur le mouvement général
démarches pour le climat donc avec
l'éveil très spontanée des jeunes qui
partent ou encore une fois sur le
continent et à partir du mouvement lancé
par greta tout de même se sont emparés
de ce sujet vraiment très très très très
passionnée passionnel et et s'y sont
investis donc deuxième point qui fait
que d'ailleurs la question du climat
était une question clé des élections
européennes
et aujourd'hui on le voit aujourd'hui
une question clé de la politique
européenne qui est développé avec le new
green deal et troisième point on avait
un débat européen qui était aussi la
très clivant qui était la question du
break site donc trois éléments qui font
que l'intérêt des citoyens étaient tout
à fait éveillé et dans le cadre je crois
des débats de grand débat national des
gilets jaunes la démocratie avait été
organisée en amont des élections même si
c'était pas le la finalité du sujet donc
ces trois points je pense sont très
intéressants 1 a souligné
merci beaucoup laurence on se tourne
maintenant vers yann wehrling justement
tu as tu as parlé de ces marches de ce
sujet effectivement on se rend compte
que le climat est mobilisateur la
question du climat notamment vers les
jeunes générations qui se mobilisent
qu'ils vont néanmoins pas forcément voté
qui trouve d'autres formes de
mobilisation alors est ce que tout ça
est compatible avec la démocratie
représentative
yann
merci fabien et puis bon jour à tout va
bien sûr à vos amis qui sont connectés
qui sont à ce débat et puis à tous ceux
qui sont connectés qui participeront pas
en direct à ce débat que je salue oui tu
as raison souligné qu'il y a et c'est
pas d'aujourd'hui que ça date un une
décorrélation entre l'engagement on va
dire dans la rue et et l'engagement dans
les urnes mais en même temps je moi je
note que c'est cette cette mobilisation
citoyenne et civique elle allait elle a
eu des phases différentes dans
l'histoire n'a vu leurs efforts dans les
années soixante dix et je dois dire que
les questions d'environnement sont
souvent un déclencheur pour les gens
dans leur engagement dans les années 70
c'était les mouvements antinucléaires
notamment qui ont beaucoup beaucoup
mobilisé au lendemain au lendemain de
mai 68 évidemment c'est difficile
certains sans moi j'étais trop j'étais
même pas nés donc mais mais en tout cas
ça a été un déclencheur à très très
puissant pour notamment la création et
la naissance de beaucoup de mouvements
écolos et il ya eu une petite apathie
après dans l'est dans les années 80 90
et là il ya un renouveau du côté de la
jeunesse notamment sur l'engagement
l'engagement sur notamment sur base de
d'enjeux environnementaux alors cédé des
enjeux on va dire générationnel cdd
moment où des générations notamment
arrivants se questionnent sur leur
avenir et les grandes questions de
l'avenir pour la jeunesse c'est
effectivement dans le dans quelle
planète mes enfants vont vivre dans quel
état va être cette planète et qui
interroge comme c'était le cas dans les
années 70 sa forme de modèle de
développement qui est qui qui se posent
des questions sur sur sur la
chemin qu'on est en train en train de
prendre et moi je dois dire que les
manifestations pour le climat qui ont
globalement pour abouti en france
notamment à des formes
on va dire où le politique a essayé de
maîtriser un peu la question et la
situation en créant notamment la
convention citoyenne pour le climat je
vois bien que ça crée des tensions
sacré ce système de démocratie
participative où on donne la parole
directement citoyens leur demande
d'écrire directement eux-mêmes à la
place des politiques et plus globalement
à la place des corps constitués
ça crée des tensions justement entre ses
citoyens qui se sentent légitimes à
pouvoir dire ce qu'ils ont envie de dire
et ces corps constitués que sont les
élus que sont les syndicats que sont les
associations qui voient ça d'un oeil
méfiant et prudent j'ai dû moi j'ai
entendu pas mal d'associations
environnementales être critique sur la
40 ans citoyenne parce que j'avais le
sentiment qu'il ya une espèce de bol on
leur voler leur légitimité de pouvoir se
dire ce qu'il faut faire et pas faire
donc c'est intéressant en fait ce qui
est en train de se passer et je pense
que c'est qu'un début merci yann on y
reviendra peut-être effectivement la
démocratie représentative doit accepter
peut-être une part plus forte de
démocratie participative ce sera tout à
l'heure avec erwan mais avant je vais me
tourner maintenant vers vers richard
richard ramos député du loiret
secrétaire général adjoint du modem
les chars tu connu pour son franc parler
tu dis les choses assez directement
est-ce que quand même réveiller la
conscience civique ça passe pas aussi
par un changement d'attitude de
vocabulaire de manière de faire chez les
élus escape a quand même petite musique
un discours qui est toujours le même et
peut-être une différence entre le dire
et le faire qui finit par lasser un peu
nos concitoyens accès c'est exactement
ça d'abord quand on dit réveiller la
conscience civique
ça veut dire la conscience des citoyens
il faut d'abord aussi réveillé la
conscience parlementaire quand on a un
texte sur la sécurité globale qui arrive
et que la moitié des gens qui le vote en
conscience je pense que c'est un mauvais
texte et qui le vote quand même
avant de faire la leçon aux autres il
faut d'abord se poser la question en
tant qu'hommes et femmes politiques
c'est quoi ma conscience comme dirait
pierre rabhi prend à part à la hauteur
de ton territoire
et puis ce qu'il fallait réveiller la
conscience ça veut dire que la
conscience elle est encore là la
conscience citoyenne
moi je crois que la conscience s'est
déplacé la conscience elle n'est plus
dans les partis politiques et la
question de cette se dire pourquoi la
conscience citoyenne cailac et vivante
chaque jour sur notre territoire on voit
des gens et des femmes des jeunes qui se
mobilisent pour faire des choses mais
les partis politiques ne sont plus le
réceptacle de la conscience citoyenne et
la question qu'il faut qu'on se pose
nous qui sommes quasiment le seul parti
capable de faire ça parce que
rappelez-vous à rattraper ou 2007 le
modem parti parti humaniste et bien nous
devons n'ont pas réveillé la conscience
mais réincarner la conscience à travers
une mouvement politique et tu l'as dit
je pense que pour réveiller ça la
question ce sera de dire aujourd'hui et
demain c'est quoi un parti politique et
donc c'est comment on pourra donner ce
mouvement là et je vais pense que oui il
faut aujourd'hui avoir un autre rapport
à l'autre et moi te le dis souvent
j'arpente la france quasiment tous les
quinze jours dans des jeux voix des
petits paysans des producteurs et c est
ma fierté alors que j'étais assez
inconnu ya trois ans c'est quasiment à
chaque fois on m'arrête on dit mais
c'était pas mal ce que vous faites
monsieur ramos parce que vous disiez pas
ce que vous dites ce que vous faites et
donc je crois que tout sera dans le
faire et je lui ai donné un exemple et
je m'arrêterai là pendant des années
j'ai eu des journaux pour enfants pour
leur apprendre à bien manger qui tirait
entre 600 mille et un million
d'exemplaires
eh bien je crois que je me suis trompée
pendant 17 ans je crois que le fait vous
rappelez de l'instruction civique
citoyens civique conscience citoyenne
stilic c'est terminé c'est à dire
prendre l'enfant pour lui expliquer ce
qu'il faut faire de façon cartésienne
professoral
le prenons comme s'ils étaient à
l'extérieur de la société est terminée
quand on est à la cantoche pendant 20
minutes
le gamin est pris pour un petit roi
qu'on va servir et peut-être qu'on va
prendre trois minutes pour nous
expliquer comment ils vont manger
non il faut le faire faire il faut qu'il
aille faire la cuisine
il faut qu'il aille en garde est ce que
c'est qu'un paysan et je pense que là
demain réveiller la conscience citoyenne
a conscience civique c'est faire les
choses et le faire ensemble et c'est à
travers ça évidemment que derrière ces
actions là nous allons construire une
pensée politique mais ça ne se fera que
dans le faire et aujourd'hui on ne nous
croit plus et donc on ne peut pas être
dans le dire et je vais voler une phrase
un marc fesneau
marcelo dit très souvent ce que tu es tu
parles plus que ce que tu dis eh bien je
pense que c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on soit
il faut pas qu'on dise nous mouvements
politiques chacun d'entre nous ce qu'il
faut faire il faut penser puisque ce
serait bien pâle bien pour la planète ça
il faut faire avec les gens et beaucoup
d'autres mouvements politiques doit se
mettre dans leurs actions
je pense que c'est comme ça non pas pour
réveillera les consciences cellules les
consciences si vite les consciences
citoyennes mais qu'on l'erea peinera
dans la conscience politique
merci beaucoup richard le faire
justement le faire faire aux citoyens
l'airé impliqués dans le processus
je vais me tourner maintenant vers vers
erwan balanant qui a ou s'est beaucoup
exprimé sur les questions de démocratie
participative
c'est à dire faire participer faire
faire dans le processus de décision
directement les citoyens
est-ce que ça remet en cause la
démocratie représentative est ce que ça
n'enrichit et puis est ce que c'est une
solution pour réveiller les consciences
il faut mettre ton micro erwan par deux
mois pardon
bonjour bonjour tout le monde merci
fabien et merci aux mouvements pour
organiser ce moment des changes sur un
sujet qui à mon avis un sujet crucial et
qui est un sujet d'une importance
absolue quand on s'appelle mouvement
démocrate
je crois que j tu viens de le dire
l'articulation entre la démocratie
participative qui émergent et la
démocratie représentative et
l'enjeu de notre de nos institutions
pour les années à venir c'est à dire que
si nous n'arrivons pas à faire ça nous
allons aller vers de plus en plus de
liens distendus entre les décideurs
publics et le citoyen parce que je t'ai
entendu dire fabien qu'il y avait un
endormissement en réalité il ya là une
sorte d'endormissement peut-être de la
routine politique
là je rejoins fabien richard pardon mais
le citoyen aujourd'hui moi j'ai
l'impression qui n'a jamais été aussi
actif en ébullition j'ai l'impression
qui a jamais eu autant de personnes à
vouloir participer à vouloir donner leur
avis alors parfois parfois ça sonne
comme une sorte de cacophonie mais tout
ça est à organiser justement et moi je
crois que l'enjeu
l'enjeu politique et institutionnel pour
les quelques années qui viennent et
quand je dis quelques années qui
viennent c'est le le la séquence qui va
aller jusqu'à la prochaine élection
présidentielle
aussi s'aider de se poser la question de
nos institutions et comment les
transforme pour que l'articulation se
fasse vraiment de façon efficace entre
cette démocratie participative et cette
démocratie représentative
on a l'exemple de la convention
citoyenne que iana citez moi je l' ai
beaucoup suivi richard richard aussi et
on voit aujourd'hui cette ébullition de
cette expérimentation démocratique
inédite 1 il n'y a jamais un pays ne la
faire une telle échelle sur un tel sujet
et sur sur autant de comment dire de de
préoccupation particulière des français
donc là vraiment on a on a cet enjeu à
résoudre et si on le fait pas si on fait
pas on va au devant de graves
déconvenues
donc voila moi je je vais perdre chez
eux merci beaucoup et roanne
on le voit la ministre nous a rejoint
alors je me mêle appelé au garde à vous
et je te laisse peut-être je vais
l'effacer droit de parole à alain thaly
haaby et lima secrétaires d'état chargés
de l'éducation prioritaire dans quelques
secondes
on a déjà un petit commentaire
effectivement sur un sujet qu'on
attendra peut-être après écarts one
connaît bien la dominique nous dit
attention au tirage au sort pour
désigner les assemblées c'est très
contestable on vient tout de suite sur
un sujet sensible mais on en reparlera
dans un moment je voudrais donner la
parole à la table des villes images qui
nous a rejoint merci beaucoup nathalie
sur la question évidemment de de
réveiller la conscience civique
on pense tout de suite à la question de
l'éducation on pense tout de suite à la
question à traiter la question à la
racine d'une certaine manière c'est à
dire des l'éducation notamment dans les
quartiers prioritaires
quel regard vous portez sur la question
qu'on se pose aujourd'hui et sur la
manière de réveiller cette conscience
civique sur la table bien bonjour à tous
vous abordez là un sujet en effet qui
est crucial à l'école et surtout qui est
qui est traité puisque l'éducation à la
citoyenneté se fait dans l'eau classe
depuis le plus jeune âge et notamment
par le biais du parcours citoyen qui
traverse tout ce qui est adossé à nos
enseignements ce parcours citoyen qu'est
ce que c'est c'est la transmission des
valeurs et les principes de la
république
en abordant tous ces grands champs qui
sont évidemment la laïcité qui sont
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et le respect mutuel c'est aussi la
lutte contre les discriminations c'est
la lutte contre les inégalités entre les
femmes et les hommes et puis
certainement un sujet dont un moine
était en train de vous parler est aussi
la lutte contre le harcèlement et jeu je
profite de cet instant pour le saluer et
surtout le remercier pour son formidable
travail dont nous nous emparons au
ministère de l'éducation nationale parce
que c'est un sujet évidemment centrale
alors ça se fait comment ça se fait
d'abord par l'instruction des élèves et
c'est notamment le cas avec
l'enseignement moral et civique qui est
une discipline que très présentes dès
l'école primaire
et puis autre sujet
très important et que l'on a
parfaitement mesuré à l'occasion de cet
événement tragique qui a été
l'assassinât absolument abjecte de
samuel pâtit c'est l'éducation aux
médias et à l'information au dos
l'instruction des élèves
elle se fait tout au long du parcours et
puis c'est aussi la mise en action des
élèves c'est à dire que les élèves
eux-mêmes s'approprient ces
enseignements le livre ensemble
travailler sur la démocratie travailler
sur la citoyenneté l'éducation à la
citoyenneté
alors ça se fait notamment par la
participation des élèves à la vie
scolaire
on a des délégués de classe en les
éco-délégués on a des conseils de vie
collégienne
encore lycéenne ça se fait aussi dans
l'engagement que l'on peut aller
chercher chez nos élèves dans des
projets citoyens avec les enseignements
je pense particulièrement à la
participation à des cérémonies
commémoratives oh oh oh
la participation individuelle ou
collective des projets citoyens aux
visites des lieux de mémoire il ya une
participation à des temps forts et à la
participation à des concours comme le
concours national de la résistance pas
encore de l'arche de la déportation une
forme d' avis qui sort évidemment aussi
l'accompagnement de nos professeurs dans
dans ses temps forts et je profite de
cette table ronde
justement pour revenir sur le
l'assassinât pardon de salut effectuent
bien réveillé chez nous des crispations
très très forte et vous redire tout ce
qui est fait tout ce qui est mise en
place à l'école
et là encore je veux saluer
véritablement l'investissement et
l'engagement de jean michel blanquer
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
depuis depuis qu'il est arrivé au
ministère en 2017 a beaucoup peu vrai en
matière de valeurs de la république et
pour le respect de la laïcité vous
rappeler tout ce qui a été mis en place
me semble aujourd'hui extrêmement
pertinents notamment à travers les
équipes valeurs de la république qui
agissent au quotidien à travers le
conseil des sages qui a délivré un
vade-mecum avec des fils parfaitement
clair pour accompagner l'ensemble de nos
de nos enseignants sur ces temps
difficiles à vivre au sein des classes
et pour mieux lutter contre contre
l'autocensure
le rapport suite à l'assassinât de
samuel patty a d'ailleurs été rendu hier
et met parfaitement en lumière que les
équipes ont bien travaillé autour de lui
pour l'accompagner au mieux même si tout
cela c'est fini malheureusement
malheureusement tragiquement enfin vous
disiez éducation prioritaire c'est vrai
que je suis secrétaire d'état chargé de
l'éducation prioritaire et là je veux
préciser aussi que enfin je lutte
véritablement contre la stigmatisation
s'est fait particulièrement odieux et
difficile se produisent dans l'ensemble
de nos établissements et je ne veux
surtout pas que l'on considère que parce
que nos élèves sont scolarisés en réseau
d'éducation prioritaire
et bien ce serait peut-être plus enclins
à c'est à ces actes parfois parfois
difficile voilà je pose un grand cadre
là comme ça et puis je crois que
l'intérêt c'est surtout de répondre à
vos questions
l'ex beaucoup nathalie n'hésitez pas à
intervenir les uns les autres et j'ai
déjà quelques questions ou quelques
halls ans qui viennent par par les
réseaux sociaux effectivement jean
bernard résume un peu ce qu'a pu dire
richard avant comment expliquer que les
français aiment la politique et m de
moins en moins les politiques
ça résume sans doute ça posera une
question à laquelle à laquelle vit chara
a assez bien répondu dans son analyse et
je voudrais me retournais vers laurence
parce que rebecca nous dit comment
mettre en place entre les parlementaires
et des citoyens des circuits plus courts
dans leur circonscription pour expliquer
les décisions publiques et faire
participer alors les députés européens
elle est plus de circonscriptions
aujourd'hui comment on raccroche quand
même le travail d'un parlementaire
européen à un terrain
précisément pour expliquer faire de la
pédagogie et et réveiller ou entretenir
cette conscience civique comment on fait
quand on est parlementaire européen les
circuits courts c'est plutôt la
spécialité de richard ramos mais je vais
essayer d'en parler quand même alors
deux choses d'abord je voulais juste te
réagir à ce que disait madame la
ministre cheikh nathalie sur sur l'école
qui est bien sûr est au coeur de tout
mais le problème c'est que l'école c'est
pas une bulle la bulle elle est souvent
au coeur d'un quartier et que en effet
on a eu des problématiques hérité
d'années et d'années et d'années de
politique de la ville à mon avis pas
très très réussi et on a cette question
de mixité qui est clé et jora je
raccrocherai ce que disait richard
hameau sûr en effet il faut que le lien
il se fasse par tous et il faut que la
république le débat il soit aussi dans
ces quartiers donc voilà on a quand même
d'aider des sujets pour nous tous qui
sommes aussi élu de proximité pour faire
en sorte qu'on puisse réintroduire
l'éducation puisque réintroduire la
culture et en plus quand même produire
la mixité sociale dans tous les
quartiers bon ça c'est une chose alors
je reviens à la question comment fait
quand on est député européen pour être
pour agir en proximité d'une part c'est
la responsabilité de chaque élu moi je
suis aussi élu local donc ça me donne
des possibilités de le faire c'est un
éclairage un peu de fourmi pour dire ben
pour y travailler pour expliciter ce qui
est son travail pour faire des visites
car il ya beaucoup de cas où l'europe si
lointaine elle commence je trouve un
mois de plus en plus être comprise en
était toute la semaine sur le terrain
avec les banques alimentaires pour dire
l'europe elles financent cette politique
de solidarité par exemple d'une manière
plus générale il ya quand même un grand
dessein au sein de notre politique
européenne actuellement qui est une
instance que nous poussons à notre
mouvement politique avec nos alliés de
gouvernement et dans le cadre de la
liste renaissance qui est ce projet de
la conférence pour l'avenir de l'europe
alors cette conférence pour l'avenir de
l'europe elle rebondit et c'est d'une
actualité triste ou nostalgique sur la
convention pour l'avenir de l'europe qui
avait été instituée par valéry giscard
d'estaing il ya présent et qui
réunissait à l'époque député commissaire
et c'est là le projet de cette
conférence pour l'avenir de l'europe est
bien de rapprocher les institutions
européennes des citoyens est donc à la
fois de créer des débats sur les grands
sujets de société que nous partageons
que ce soit l'environnement la défense
le l'élargissement enfin voilà tous les
grands problèmes que nous pouvons
traiter mais aussi à terme de pouvoir
infléchir les traités qui font que par
exemple les parlementaires européens
n'ont pas le droit d'initiative sur les
lois que la réflexion si sur la création
de listes transnationales
voilà donc ce projet il encourt on sent
que c'est une démarche très compliqué
parce que il ya des freins au sein des
institutions se dit tiens est ce qu'on
va être dépossédé d'une partie des
prérogatives législatives
mais déjà ce point juste un petit aussi
un petit ajout sur le rôle de l'europe
il ya la question bien sûr là
l'expression citoyenne civique alex
elles existent pour beaucoup sur les
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui donc c'est
un sujet à part entière et cette
régulation on l'a vu dans le drame qui a
touché samuel pâtit la législation sur
la haine en ligne sur la régulation des
contenus ça à tous les parlementaires
que nous sommes à tous leurs niveaux
nous avons un rôle absolument clé sur ce
sujet pour faire en sorte que la
démocratie dans ce nouveau réceptacle
qui change beaucoup de choses elles
soient régulés aussi merci je vais
revenir vers richard richard
certains ont souvenir d'une action qui
avait mené pendant le confinement qui
consistait à distribuer du gel
hydroalcoolique dans sa circonscription
et ça avait donné lieu à quelques
reportages
alors c'est dû faire c'est ce que tu as
dit tout à l'heure à moroni au passo
faire on est dans l'action concrète mais
j'ai envie de te poser une question un
peu provocatrice qu est-ce que c'est le
rôle d'un parlementaire de faire ça
aujourd'hui ce que le parlementaire il
est dans le faire ou est ce qu'il n'est
pas aussi ailleurs normalement sur un
autre terrain un terrain qui est pas
facilement compris des français
peut-être qui est celui de la
à qui n'est jamais assez bonne jamais
assez rapide etc mais est ce que c'était
vraiment le rôle d'un parlementaire
c'est très compliqué la capote la
question est très pertinente
on me reproche mois souvent quand je
vais défendre le bien manger quand vous
verrez dans le journal du dimanche une
grande page de dimanche sur un sujet
auquel on a interviewé
est ce que c'est à moi d'aller défendre
sur les territoires en france là où les
salopards l'industriel empoisonnent les
français parce qu'ils veulent faire plus
de fric
est ce que c'est à moi d'aller sur un
plateau de télé comme pour dire on a mis
un chorizo espagnols et ceux chorizo
dedans y'a pas les ingrédients qui
seront autorisés en france et en europe
et c'est moi qui tu es et c'est moi qui
vais faire avec 150 euros
l'analyse du chorizo je ne sais pas si
c'est aux députés de faire ça mais en
tout cas le député ce n'est pas celui
qui est sans fermerait aux 126 rue de
l'université et qui ferait des lois qui
seraient déconnectés du terrain et donc
moi je pense au contraire que c'est le
rôle du député
je suis alors on est à la fois des
députés terrain est à la fois des
députés de la nation et donc la question
est de savoir est ce qu'on anticipait
demande sociétale ou est-ce qu'on court
après est ce qu on laisse notre jeunesse
nous dire comme dirait yann wehrling de
regarder la biodiversité
et puis une fois qu'on a vu que c'est un
sujet parce que ça ferait des électeurs
dans les urnes
on pourrait se les approprier dans le
parlement mais c'est pas ça nous sommes
les représentants de la nation et
entendent représentants de la nation on
doit anticiper la société pas courir
derrière et est donc je crois que oui
c'est le rôle du député
c'est le rôle du député sur son
périmètre sur son couloir de nage
d'aller pied appliquée eu de demain dans
1 an dans un paysan qui nous appellent
kindy eux
je n'arrive pas à travailler aujourd'hui
avec la grande distribution
un autre qui nous dit e.on va mais on va
on va me payer comme je l'avais fait
vous avez vous avait déversé une tonne
d'oignons devant un auchan avec mon
écharpe ou le paysan était payé 7
centimes revendu de 0,49
est-ce que c'est mon rôle dans les
réponses des chats déverser une tonne
d'oignons
la réponse est oui pour moi et peut-être
que je suis un mauvais députés je n'en
sais rien mais en tout cas je pense que
le parlement c'est pas celui qui court
derrière
toc c'est celui qui le comprend et qui
anticipe la société merci beaucoup
richard nathalie voulait intervenir et
après une relance pour yann également
sur la convention citoyenne nathalie oui
merci beaucoup
bravo richard pour ce que tu viens de
dire je te reconnais bien là et je
partage à 100 % ton monte on propos
évidemment que le rôle d'un
parlementaire et je vais même dire que
c'est aussi et surtout le rôle d'un
membre du gouvernement
c'est bien d'être d'abord et surtout sur
sur le terrain et tout ce que tu as fait
vendre le confinement et que d'autres
parlementaires en fait je te félicite
encore une fois et c'est exactement ce
qu'il fallait faire moi même dans mon
périmètre et j'ai été très frustré là
comme vous tous ces derniers temps
puisqu'il nous a fallu être confinés et
bien je fais et je déroule la politique
qui est la mienne et je construis les
projets de réforme
d'abord et surtout à partir du terrain
parce que c'est là qu'on va prendre le
thé c'est là que l'on mesure
parfaitement nos difficultés
je veux aussi vous alerter mais on en
est tous ici
conscient sur le jeu vous invite
vraiment à regarder de près le dernier
rapport pauvreté là qui vient d'être
publié et qui est absolument alarmant
catastrophique on le voit sur les
demandes d aide alimentaire qui sont
explosives
on a de nouveaux publics on a des
familles des familles monoparentales les
gens qui précédemment arriver à boucler
leurs mois et qui aujourd'hui n'y arrive
plus peut-être que ce sera abordée
aujourd'hui il ya le cas des jeunes il
ya des étudiants qui ne vont plus qu'ils
ne suivent que leurs cours qui sont
privées de leurs petits boulots tout ça
c'est particulièrement dramatique et
c'est sur le terrain que l'on prend le
pouls de tout ça et c'est en discutant
avec les gens que l'on veut rectifier et
les les bonnes réponses donc c'est un
kit réaction à ce que disait richard et
que je soutiens bien évidemment natal
est justement une question pour vous qui
vient d'arriver sur sur les réseaux
sociaux
n'at-elle pas urgence à réinvestir le
champ d'éducation populaire où l'on
constate que les jeunes peuvent être
séduits par des discours fondamentaliste
ou identitaire oui très probablement
même certainement et d'ailleurs c'est ce
que nous faisons aussi
sur le territoire est là pour le coup je
moi je vais répondre davantage dans mon
périmètre que c'est à dire celui de
l'éducation prioritaire
nous mettons en place un travail et un
maillage extrêmement fin avec les
associations justement en ce sens à
travers les sites et éducative
je rappelle qu'il ya 80 cité éducative
ce territoire j'en ai annoncé 40
supplémentaires et je vais vous dire le
fond de ma pensée c'est même aujourd'hui
largement insuffisant en tout cas les
associations ya un véritable partenariat
mené avec l'ensemble des acteurs sur le
territoire la maison éducation nationale
fait évidemment son travail mais nous
travaillons aussi en lien très étroit et
je m'y emploie avec les élus tous les
élus avec les associations d'élus et
tous ceux qui sont sur le terrain et en
particulier avec les maires parce
qu'encore une fois ce sont eux qui
prennent la température la plus fine des
deux de ce qui se passe dans leur dans
leur commune mais aussi avec les
associations en ayant encore tout même
un regard particulier sur leur
attachement véritable aux valeurs de la
république et en faisant très attention
à ce qu'elle ne déborde pas de ce champ
là mais bien sûr qu'il faut reprendre du
terrain et c'est ce que nous faisons et
jeux en tous cas moins c'est ce que je
m'efforce à faire avec tous les acteurs
voudraient maintenant me tourner à la
fois vers vers yann et vert erwan on a
évoqué la question de la convention
citoyenne qui a été un exercice
effectivement inédit et qui a sans doute
contribué à réveiller la conscience
civique
néanmoins on a vu aussi qu'il y avait un
hiatus entre les décisions prises et
leur mise en oeuvre
leur exécution on voit bien que c'est
pas si simple de mettre en oeuvre un
certain nombre de mesures et que
peut-être soit hiatus créer un
endormissement une défiance en tout cas
de plus en plus forte comment on peut
résoudre seul hiatus ou faire de la
pédagogie ou expliqué qu'un certain
nombre de mesures fusse-t-elle
souhaitable ou peuvent pas se mettre en
oeuvre du jour au lendemain
yann et roanne ou erwan gagnent comme
vous voulez un nazi awan sympa
non oui non c'est une question assez
complexe en réalité mais mais en salle
c'est la convention citoyenne est
extrêmement intéressante parce qu'on
voit on voit aujourd'hui des citoyens
qui ont qui ont participé et c'est pour
ça que je trouve que c'est intéressant
que des citoyens parfois puisse être
tiré au sort on pourra dire un mot sur
le tirage au sort après mais que les
citoyens ont travaillé ils ont travaillé
avec avec les fonctionnaires des
administrations centrales et aussi avec
les ong et puis ils ont ils ont proposé
un certain nombre de deux dispositifs
certaines relèvent de la loi certaines
relèvent du domaine réglementaire et
aujourd'hui on est en train de le
gouvernement est en train de finaliser
l'écriture du texte qui va porter cet
cette loi qui va être qui va porter ces
mesures législatives qui va être une
grande loi 2 du quinquennat ça va être
ça va être un texte énorme extrêmement
important où on va avoir des grandes
avancées et puis c'est vrai qu'à une
petite incompréhension entre parfois les
citoyens qui pensent que on va pas assez
vite mais ce ils se confrontent en
réalité à allah à toute la difficulté de
la décision politique et nathalie elle
le connaît aussi maintenant qu'elle est
de l'autre côté et au niveau du
gouvernement c'est à dire qu'entre
l'absolu où on veut aller et puis la
réalité du terrain c'est extrêmement
compliqué donc il ya ce travail de
pédagogie à faire et d'articulation à
faire juste sur le sur le rôle justement
par rapport à ce que disait richard
richard c'est un bon député et mai mais
il a bien parlé de couloirs de nage et
c'est intéressant parce que c'est
justement ça il ya des députés qui
nagent qui nagent le crawl il ya des
députés qui font du papillon et y en a
qui vont nager sur le dos ce que je veux
dire par là c'est qu'on a chacun nos
spécialités et nos domaines
d'intervention et moi par exemple qui
suit commissaire aux lois alors
effectivement je le travaille moi sur
les sujets agricoles vient qu'en lien
avec ma circonscription je le fais et ça
sur le terrain de tous les week-ends on
et voilà mais mais par contre quand
quand on travaille sur les prisons bas
lister les prisons et autres et on passe
du temps dans les prisons c'est un
exemple par exemple donc voilà mais
chaque député à ces domaines et chaque
député a son style et le style de
richard est inégalable évidemment mais
voilà mais bon toujours est il que sur
cette question de l'articulation et je
vais dire un mot du tirage au sort
parce que je sens qu'elle est parfois
sur le tirage au sort
je sais que françois si nous écoutent
n'est pas du tout un grand fan du tirage
au sort mais le tirage au sort n'est pas
n'est pas n'a aucune vocation à
remplacer l'élu le tirage au sort il
permet d'avoir un travail
comment dire un travail d' analyse de la
réalité du des citoyens parce que les
avantages du tirage au sort c'est qu'on
peut tirer au sort des gens qui ne
participent pas habituellement
vous savez très bien quand vous faites
une réunion publique où une réunion de
quartier vous avez toujours les mêmes
qui se sont les mêmes qui parlent ce
sont des richard ramos qui vont qui vont
ouvrir sur les citoyens professionnels
comme on les appelle
voilà non mais c'est vrai et l'avantagé
du tirage au sort ça permet d'aller dans
des angles morts des gens qui n'auraient
jamais participé à la politique et qui
se retrouve là qui se retrouvent à
donner un avis et c'est intéressant et
mais c'est pas eux qui vont faire la
décision et on le voit sur la convention
citoyenne et je vais conclure là dessus
la convention citoyenne elle sera elle
sera votée par les parlementaires
on aura eu un travail avec eux et c'est
tout l'enjeu de faire ce travail c'est
le sait l'enjeu et c'est la difficulté 1
parce que eux ils se sentent investis
d'une mission mais c'est pas eux qui
vont faire la loi au bout du compte et
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
articuler donc voila et les tirs elle
tient le pour moi la démocratie
participative n'a pas vocation à
remplacer la démocratie représentative
elle a vocation à la halle à l'enrichir
à apprendre en le pouls de de cette
citoyenneté émergentes qui n'a pas non
plus nécessairement envie d'être élu et
de et de travailler ensemble pour que
chaque opinion dans notre pays soit soit
brison est d'ailleurs générale de nous
dit depuis la haute loire qu'il ressent
aussi effectivement cette envie dont la
sienne
cette fois de participation directe et
aux décisions ils en témoignent sur les
réseaux sociaux
yann sur cette question également du
temps d'abord d'abord moi j'aime bien
débattre avec richard parce que ils me
réveillent et il nous réveillent tous et
ça c'est super parce que je trouve qui
il a dit quelque chose qui traduit
quelque chose de très de très fort c'est
qu'il faut pas oublier quand on est
engagé
que ce soit parlementaire aux militants
s'il n'y a pas de différence pour moi de
ce point de vue là faut pas oublier
d'être militant faut pas oublier d'être
engagé faut pas oublier de porter la
voix de donner ses idées et de pas juste
être parce qu'il ya cette tendance
canton une fois qu'on est élu on a des
phases
on y réfléchit tous et il ya des
familles et des espaces où on sait on
devient organisateur du débat on devient
quasiment on veut faire aussi bien que
le haut fonctionnaire qui nous
accompagnent en terme de technicité non
c'est pas notre rôle notre rôle il est
vraiment d'être des militants et des
engagés faut pas l'oublier et je crois
que c'est quand on oublie que on a on se
suicide du questionnement dans la
société en suicide du questionnement
dans la population qui ne sait plus on
veut aller qui ne connaît plus nos idées
qui sait plus ce qu'on veut faire et qui
se mobilisent alors on a des mouvements
populaires on a des mouvements citoyens
qui finit nous nous interrogent et moi
il ya une question au fond qui me
questionnent fins et c'est quand ça se
passe ça qu'on entendait des mouvements
citoyens quand on a des mouvements
parfois dures comme les gilet jaune par
exemple mais quand on écoute les
revendications des jeunes et des jeunes
pour le climat parfois c'est très
radicale aussi et que derrière la
réponse est d'organiser des grands
débats d'organiser des conventions
citoyenne et que derrière on n'en fait
rien c'est c'est terrible en fait
en fait le la rupture elle et elle est
absolument absolument dramatique parce
que ou encore huit mois je me rappelle
du grand débat qu'ont organisé au
lendemain d'un gilet jaune
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on en a fait mais
je ne sais pas aujourd'hui est ce qu'on
en a fait et c'est très important de de
dunes pas de ne pas tromper les gens
quand on leur dit on vous donne la
parole ça c'est très très problématique
et et moi sur la convention citoyenne
j'ai beau a je crois qu'on a perdu yann
malheureusement d'un seul coup pardon
erwan tu voulais rebondir
ouais alors je ne sais pas ce qu'il
allait dire exactement sur la convention
citoyenne mais moi je je je je ne peux
pas laisser dire qu'on n'a rien fait
c'est pas vrai cette convention
citoyenne elle va aboutir à sur un grand
texte un texte qui qui qui va être un
texte je veux dire on va y passer un
sacré bout de temps et ça va
particulièrement changer la vie des
français dans là dedans là dans les
années qui vont venir parce que sur la
convention citoyenne à l'issue de la
convention citoyenne on va prendre un
certain nombre de décisions et richard
le sait aussi certaines décisions qui
étaient bloqués dans les tiroirs des des
ministères depuis dix ans ça fait dix
ans que c'est c'est comment dire
certaines de ses dispositions certains
de ses textes certaines de ces lois on
n'osait pas à les prendre
on a nous les hommes et les femmes
politiques n'osais pas les prendre
et là il ya eu un coup d'accélérateur
kiki et qui est évident alors vous avez
des gens comme céline dion qui
continuent à dire qu on est en
régression sur les questions
environnementales moi je suis désolé
quand on avance on recule pas alors
peut-être qu'on n'avance pas assez vite
pour lui et ça c'est légitime et c'est
très bien qu'ils continuent à le dire
parce que je pense effectivement que on
avancera on a encore il faut encore
avancé plus mais voilà donc voilà est ce
pareil le grand débat le grand débat
certes c'était un grand débat on a
débattu
la france a débattu il ya peut-être pas
eu d'atterrissage sur le grand débat
mais il ya quand même eu un atterrissage
pas inintéressant et laurence l'a
signalé tout à l'heure c'est que on a eu
plus 8 % de participation à aux
élections européennes qui ont suivi et
je suis sûr que si elle pas eu ce grand
départ on n'aurait pas eu ces 8 %
c'est-à-dire que plus on aura de la
démocratie participative plus on aura du
débat citoyen plus on aura ce genre d'
échanges plus les parties feront leur
travail aussi de d'aller sur le terrain
et plus on aura des gens à aller voter
parce que les gens ils vont pas voter
parfois comme l'a dit richard parce
qu'ils ont et comme l'a dit
aussi yann c'est qu'ils ont l'impression
qu'on ce qu'on les connaît comment dire
un peu installé sur nos d'automatique
convaincu voilà nan mais je crois que
les députés je pense qu'on me fait assez
bien les députés du groupe modem c'est
qu'il faut qu'on montre qu'on n'est en
questionnement tout le temps on est tout
le temps en questionnement moi j'avoue
que je passe ma vie à me poser des
questions même sur tous les textes et me
dire bon c'est un texte du gouvernement
mais est ce que est ce que c'est la
bonne solution et c'est pour ça par
exemple que je suis monté au créneau sur
l'article 24 de la loi sécurité globale
avec avec comment dire laurence contre
l'avis d'une autre partie du groupe il
faut le dire aussi qu'il ya des gens
dans le groupe qui était pour cet
article 24 on a eu un débat et c'est ça
qui fait que les citoyens vont se
réconcilier à mon avis avec les
personnalités politiques les femmes et
les hommes qui s'engagent directement
sur le mandat électif présent qu'ils
voient que nous nous posons des
questions
je crois qu'à roanne tu as complètement
raison sur cette idée de ne pas être
godillots comme on l'entend parfois mais
d'avoir un vrai débat richard voulait
réagir mais puisque vous êtes tous les
deux parlementaires nationaux la
question revient évidemment dans les
commentaires pour réveiller la
conscience civique il faut que la
représentation nationale soit plus à
l'image du peuple est évidemment vous me
voyez venir c'est la question de la
proportionnelle à laquelle on est très
attaché quand comment évidemment ce
sujet questionne nos militants et nos
sympathisants
richard moi je préfère cours sur la
proportionnelle macron nous avait promis
la proportionnelle c'est pour ça qu'il a
été élu grâce au modem et à françois
bayrou il doit tenir son engagement
et si demain on n'a pas de
proportionnelle on a un risque demain
d'avoir des populistes avec tous les
pouvoirs au parlement au parlement et
donc on nous doit s'approprier réel il
faut qu'en jeu back dessus et pour moi
ça c'est la promesse du président macro
qui a été sept à françois bayrou
elle doit être respectée et donc je
pense que là on a on va avoir dans les
mois qui viennent dans les semaines qui
viennent même un combat qui va être très
puissant
moi je voudrais juste rajouter quelque
chose pour le modem en cantonais au
congrès du modem
je pense que sur ses engagements
citoyenne la participation citoyenne
le modem ne doit pas se dire tout le
temps ce qu'il a été
évidemment on le voit bien avec la
république en marche
nous avons des racines qu'ils n'ont pas
et qu'à la première tempête
l'arbre du modèle qu'un des grandes
raskin même s'il est moins ou celui de
la république en marche thiam et aux
tempêtes
c'est la nature comme ça d'avoir des
racines profondes mais la question qu'on
doit se poser
nous le modem aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
que ce que nous avons été mais ce que
nous serons la société est en mouvement
qu'est ce qu'on met aujourd'hui dans
l'idéal l'idéologie modèle on voit bien
aujourd'hui qu'il ya même à d'écart
entre nos adhérents qui nous écoutent
très écologiste et peut-être des fusions
nationale et donc s'est refondée avec le
modem
la possibilité évidente et l'évidente de
construire l'avenir
et ça nous devons bien en prendre en
compte pour pas se gargariser de ce
qu'on a été mais qu'est ce qu'on est
aujourd'hui dans le logiciel modèle et
ça pour moi c'est ses fondamentaux et
fondamentale on le voit même des
adhérents qui mise en garde en disant au
siège là bas vous êtes vous êtes vous
répondez jamais vous vous êtes vous à
quoi nos préoccupations
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait en interne
pour s'appliquer à nous-mêmes ce qu'on
veut qu'on appliquait à la frénésie
c'est très juste également et on aura
l'occasion dans cette journée notamment
présenté le travail d'université 133 il
questionne précisément ce qu'est le
centre ce qu'il a été excellent travail
il est aujourd'hui qui était vraiment un
travail très intéressante à restituer
devant l'été dans les semaines qui
viennent et en parallèle d'ailleurs sera
annoncée aussi tout à l'heure un travail
autour de la démocratie a particip de
comment lutter précisément contre
l'abstention et et favoriser la
conscience civique mais jean-noël barrot
on parlera alors à tout à l'heure
laurence du dialogue avec des
parlementaires d'autres pays
ces questions les autres parlementaires
se les posent vous en parlez ce sujet
n'est pas que français
est ce que tu as des éléments sur un
petit peu comment tes collègues modéré
centriste vivent aussi ces questions-là
ailleurs en europe
ils ont que ce débat on l'a à l'échelon
européen sur ce que je citais tout à
l'heure la conférence pour l'avenir de
l'europe
il ya eu un peu partout en europe des
expériences sur la pâte en la d alors il
ya plusieurs choses via la façon de
faciliter les les élections donc la
question aussi de qu'on a abordé et que
jean-noël barrot a mis au top de
l'agenda comme on dit sur le vote à
distance le vote électronique et toutes
ces choses qui sont aussi très
importantes pour faciliter la démocratie
au plan européen
nous traitons ça de manière globale donc
encore une fois cette ce combat pour
l'avenir de leurs piles et pour la
conférence de l'avenir de l'europe il
est clé pour nous unifier sur cette
représentativité direct donc on l'a
vraiment à ce niveau là et dans notre
groupe centriste renew c'est vraiment
connaissance parce que sinon je vais me
faire engueuler par le président on est
on est vraiment sur ce combat pour la
démocratie on est dans au sein du groupe
il n'y a pas que des majoritaires on est
on sait aussi qu'on a des cons cohabite
avec démocrate des démocraties plus ou
moins libéral voirie libéral comme le
prouvent les blocages en cours parce
qu'on est en train de discuter de l'état
de droit
on est sur des niveaux de maturité
démocratique assez hétérogène à un plan
européen
donc là encore une fois on visse et ses
contrastes et ses contrastes en essais
de les outrepasser de les dépasser par
l'échelon transnationales et par
l'échelon par l'échelon d'une réflexion
robes et voilà comment ça ce ça se
traduit il ya en effet et pour ce qui
est de notre combat et débat national
moi je rejoins tout à fait l'obligation
qu'a aujourd'hui le
vernement de de mettre sur la table ce
débat sur la proportionnelle et de le
conclure parce que c'est l'engagement
très fort et en effet si on n'a pas
cette bonne représentativité de tous les
citoyens
il ya une étude qui est vraiment très
intéressante qui a été fait sur ce sujet
sur le fait qu' aujourd'hui et demain
80 % des votes pour être des votes de
contestation soit par le vote
l'abstention le vote blanc ou les
extrêmes c'est un véritable danger donc
il faut lire et montre un cadavre en
bleu le crash test olivier nous dit
qu'effectivement se pose dans ce cas la
part de proportionnelle pour ne pas
retomber dans les errements de la
quatrième république c'est un vrai débat
mais avant de passer la parole à droite
je voudrais questionner nathalie parce
qu'on a une question qui nous est arrivé
ou plutôt une affirmation qui illustre
ce que vous avez dit nathalie le
problème de la démocratie c'est
l'absence d'éducation civique dans les
écoles des plus jeune âge il n'ya pas
d'absence il y en a on a beaucoup parlé
des enseignants
comment on implique aussi les parents
dans ce processus là et comment comment
aussi la puissance publique joue avec la
sphère familiale parce que cette
question de la conscience civique ne pas
passer que par les enseignants c'est une
excellente question qui est celle de
l'implication des familles elle vous
savez mon attachement particulier à ce
sujet et même à la restauration d'une
politique familiale forte dans notre
pays d'ailleurs en quittant avant quitté
l'assemblée j'avais rendu un rapport en
ce sens
largement soutenu par mon groupe
donc je salue à nouveau nos
parlementaires présents sur cette table
ronde
et puis je profite aussi de ceux de ce
moment pour remercier à nouveau patrick
mignola notre le président de groupe à
l'assemblée nationale j'ai encore envie
de dire notre ce que je me sens
évidemment toujours très attaché à ce
groupe et qui me manque beaucoup et puis
avant lui à marc marc fesneau
évidemment qu'il faut il faut pardon
travailler toujours plus avec les
familles
on l'a vu d'ailleurs à l'occasion de la
crise des gilet jaune tels que le
soulignait yann wehrling on l'a revu la
pendant la
période de confinement au finalement la
famille a repris tout son sens et elle
est redevenue parce qu'elle est réapparu
en tout cas pour ce qu'elle est c'est à
dire un plier absolument central et on
voit bien aujourd'hui si on a des
dérives certaines dérives chez nos
jeunes c'est parce que justement il y a
là aussi un problème et c'est vrai que
l'école a eu quelques réticences
il faut l'admettre a laissé entrer les
familles à l'école c'est un peu la bulle
vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs le pré carré
des professeurs et pourtant pardon on
voit bien là combien c'est nécessaire et
ce travail je veux le dire a vraiment
été repris il a été repris un petit peu
à marche forcée pendant le confinement
parce que il a fallu aller chercher tous
nos élèves au moment où apparaissaient
très clairement cette fracture numérique
dont peut-être on reparlera et qui a
éloigné certains de nos élèves est
vraiment les parents les professeurs
pardon sont retournés ont repris contact
avec les familles et nous travaillons
aussi beaucoup en ce sens aujourd'hui
alors ça ça commence très tôt par
l'éducation à la parentalité et là c'est
un travail que je mène en partenariat
avec mon collègue adrien taquet mais
bien sûr que la place des familles et
centra il faut parfois il faut le dire
rééduquer certaines familles et surtout
ne pas oublier de dire que à l'école on
a un rôle fondamental à jouer
d'éducation de nos enfants les premiers
acteurs ce sont bien évidemment les
parents et qu'il faut absolument ramener
chacun dans son périmètre
le professeur est ce qu'il est et il
doit d'abord et avant tout être
respectée et d'ailleurs ça avait été
très clairement crantée dans le texte
pour une école de la confiance qui avait
porté jean michel blanquer
le professeur doit être respectée mais
la famille aussi en tant que tel et il
faut bien évidemment la réintégrer et je
reviens sur les propos que je tenais
précédemment c'est à dire travailler
tous ensemble autour de nos enfants avec
tous les acteurs qui sont présents et en
premier lieu bien évidemment leurs
parents pour créer j'ai même envie de
dire de recréer du commun de commencer
bien ce qui nous manque aujourd'hui où
chacun est un petit peu dans son
périmètre nous sommes les uns à côté des
autres et nous ne sommes plus les uns
avec les autres et donc il ya un travail
ça va de pair ou vous parler de ces
conventions citoyenne vous parler de
tous ces échanges mais ça commence
d'abord par la nécessité que nous avons
à recréer du commun et en ce sens ce que
font nos parlementaires à aller sur le
terrain à être exemplaire sur le terrain
et bien je crois que ça commence merci
nathalie erwan voulait réagir ton micro
erwan ton micro ton micro la one au
micro oui dans certaines réactions à un
propos qui est parti donc de dodge en
est passé sur autre chose donc il n'ya
pas il n'y a pas d'urgence de réaction
aurait dit y a plus d'urgence de
réactions je sais je j'avais une
réaction sur le sur le vif tout à
l'heure je sais même plus sur quoi
c'était pour trier le cachet sans doute
peut-être pas si important que ça mais
par contre justine unis un complément
d'information sur ce que vient de dire
nathalie sur sur quelque chose qui me
semblait extrêmement importants et moi
je les ai vus sûrement sur mon travail
quand sous travail que j'ai fait pendant
six mois là sur le harcèlement scolaire
la question de l'articulation parents
professeurs et institutions scolaires
école est extrêmement important j'ai pas
par par un certain nombre de mu 2 les
parents se sont retrouvé un peu éloigné
de l'école et même un peu interdits
d'école il ya eu des questions de
vigipirate où les parents ne rentre plus
dans l'école
maintenant il ya les questions de
sanitaires ou les parents rentrent
encore moins dans l'école et et pour moi
c'est un vrai problème
il y a eu il ya eu au désastre et je le
dis je ne sais pas je vais peut-être me
faire des ennemis mais la fin de l'école
du samedi matin
c'est une c'est un désastre pour pour
nos écoles parce que c'était le moment
où les femmes y avait un peu de temps de
deux pour aller à l'école pour passer du
temps avec parfois les professeurs et
les instituteurs donc je crois qu'il
faut ça c'est un vrai sujet c'est
comment on réagit kull les enfants les
parents et les profs parce que il ya un
lien qui doit se créer un lien important
les enseignants
ont une culture justement autour de ce
commun autour de 7,2 des valeurs de
notre république et je pense que si on
pouvait avoir des parents plus en lien
avec les années les instituteurs et les
professeurs ça serait quelque chose de
très profitable à notre société avant
voilà ça c'était une petite réaction sur
ce sujet avant 2 avant de conclure il
nous reste encore quelques minutes jeu
pour la conclusion je proposerai à
chacun d'eux de retenir peut être un
élément comment réveiller la conscience
civique chacun pourra nous donner un
élément l'élément peut-être qu'ils qui
polluent le plus important mais avant
cette conclusion on a effleuré tout à
l'heure richard notamment la question
des partis politiques
comment on rend de nouveau les
mouvements politiques attractif et c'est
une question que je pose à toutes et à
tous d'ailleurs comment selon vous on
permet aux partis politiques de
redevenir attractif parce que c'est
d'ailleurs un fait assez rare
je pense qu'aujourd'hui aucune formation
politique ne peut prétendre à être
extrêmement attractive alors qu'il avait
toujours suivant les époques telle ou
telle formation qui était plus ou moins
attractive aujourd'hui c'est une un
problème que tous traversent comment
être de nouveau attractif qui souhaitent
répondre
richard peut-être qu'il avait effleuré
le sujet tout à l'heure est ce que tu
démarres bien d'abord je pense que le
mouvement démocrate et le parti qui peut
incarner la meilleure attractivité
je le pense parce qu'on a tous les
fondamentaux pour le faire mais on ne le
pourra le faire que sur un projet cirque
aujourd'hui on va pas dire à quelqu'un
écoute vient prendre une carte modem
parce que la carte et orange
elle viens viens prendre modèle parce
que j'ai un projet avec société à
proposer et regardez nos conseils
municipaux dans les territoires on a
souvent des femmes qui sont arrivés
parce qu'elle arrive dans le village
depuis 5 6 ans et parce qu'elle veut
s'impliquer parce qu'elles ont des
enfants et veulent s'impliquer dans la
cité mais il s'implique parce que la
municipalité est porteur d'un projet et
on ne pourra refaire venir chez nous en
masse jeudi vient en masse l'objectif
c'est de faire du volume
excusez moi de parler aussi crûment que
ce qu'ils m'ont porte un projet fort et
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas se passer
théo modèle de nous dire que ce qu'on a
été parce que nous sommes et parce que
nous avons besoin de savoir qui on a été
ça ne suffira pas à faire réagir et donc
on ne le fera que c'est des projets et
donc après en fonction des uns des
autres en fonction des présidents de
fédérations qui nous écoutent jeu j'ai
eu il n'y a pas très longtemps que ce
soit guy torreilles que ça soit
véronique les chaises le rouge
que ça soit sciemment à saint-etienne
des présidents et présidentes de fait
dès qu'ils ne disent rien sur ce sujet
là comment on va faire ensemble
localement et donc c'est que chacun au
mouvement démocrate à son strates simple
adhérent adhérents conseiller municipal
adhérents adjoint adhérents mer à des
vents président eh bien c'est ensemble
qu'on va réussir parce que on va mettre
des projets on va hiérarchiser nos
projets avaient pu le penser
notamment avec laurence qu'elle eut une
pensée européenne
quelques notes keynote et notre notre
adn j'ai envie de dire et on va décliner
le projet qui est un grand projet de vie
mondiale se dire qu'est ce qu'on propose
comme comme la france des lumières
qu'est ce qu'on propose au monde
je viens au monde comme modèle de
société et chacun à notre niveau
les députés européens comme leurs
hanches nous les des parlementaires
français vous les présidents et les
adhérents du modem nous re déclineront
en fonction de notre territoire et notre
périmètre de chacun ce ces projets là
mais je pense que si on sait ça chacun à
notre place on va faire revenir beaucoup
de monde au modem merci laisser à
quelqu'un d'autre souhaite réagir sur
les partis politiques
sinon je oui oui c'est wang ce qui suit
est heureux de voir des clients
one way je vais et je vais très rapide
et je vais exactement dans le sens de
richard c'est à dire que un parti
politique qui sera attractif aujourd'hui
c'est un parti politique qui va proposer
un projet de société avec un peu ce en
ayant peur sans avoir peur aussi de
parler d'utopie dans le sens de ce
qu'elle le sens réel de l'utopie de
tadderte de créer des projets à kiki qui
sont des projets désiré et c'est ça
qu'il faut qu'on arrive à faire et
richard a complètement raison et je
pense qu'il faut qu'on
on avait fait un travail remarquable et
qui maintenant date un peu et je pense
qu'il serait bien qu'on puisse avoir de
nouveau à une sorte de grand congrès
fondateur et de 2,2 sur les idées
c'était arras et arras en 2008 était un
moment extraordinaire et je pense qu'il
faut qu'on ait de nouveau nos draps
assez rapidement et qu'on est toutes les
préoccupations aussi on est orange mais
il faut qu'on se on se borde d'un liseré
vert tout autour de notre orange pour
pour comment dire pour avancer sur les
questions environnementales parce que il
ya moi je vois deux enjeux dans notre
société c'est l'articulation de la
démocratie avec la vie des citoyens et
la question de la transition écologique
et les deux sont les deux sont sous se
répondent souvent et je pense qu'il ya
là dessus il va pouvoir compléter
mais si tu me permet à roanne c'était un
bon un bon mot de conclusion pour te
concernant démocratie écologie deux
enjeux majeurs qui réveille les
consciences civique tu as raison c'est
mobilisateur je vous pose la question je
commence par nathalie puylaurens comment
réveiller les consciences civique le mot
de la fin en découle une de minutes
chacun avant qu'on rende l'antenne n'a
fait si alors rapidement moi je rejoins
évidemment ce qu'elle dit richard sur le
projet je crois que l'adhésion elle
passe par un projet je reviendrai aussi
sur le commun parce qu'évidemment il
faut qu'ils soient communs que tout le
monde puisse se l'approprier et donc je
pense qu'il faut inverser la verticalité
on nous a souvent attaqué critiqué mais
c'est notamment apparue très fortement
la crise des jeunes sur la verticalité
de nos décisions et bien je crois qu'il
faut l'inversé cette verticalité ce
qu'il faut absolument que tout parte du
terrain et de nos territoires et de nos
et de nos élus
alors pour en revenir un petit peu sur
sur les partis et là sur notre notre
formation politique moi j'ai envie de
parler d'une famille politique parce que
nous sommes nous sommes d'abord et avant
tout une grande famille
les grandes familles politiques
peut-être le moment est il venu aussi de
lourds
être en question sur notre mode de
fonctionnement sur notre façon de
travailler et donc d'être plus ouverts
et d'être attractif sur notre façon
aussi de mieux accueillir et de mieux
intégrer nos jeunes parce que notre
formation politique est là d'ailleurs
les instances jeunes viennent de se
renouveler et je salue notre ami auguste
mothe et avant lui aurélien leveaux
l'amant de presse beaucoup il faut que
je vous conclurez aller très vite donc
recrue du commun faisons le tous
ensemble et à partir d'abord et toujours
de et territoires laurence ya lessarat
laurence la question est toujours de
créer de la différenciation je pense
qu'aujourd'hui dans l'offre politique
finalement il ya une ligne de fracture
qui est un petit peu trop marquées entre
les partis radicaux clivant qui vont
vers les extrémismes et puis les parties
plus démocrates au sein de ça il faut
qu'on fasse entendre une différence
qu'on a et la différence qu'on a un pour
moi elle se résume en deux mots c'est
l'enracinant en a parlé et notre liberté
et notre liberté
elle nous permettre d'être innovant ou
d'être vraiment dans une écoute plus
forte que celle que peut-être on a pu
avoir jusque là pour traiter de nos
grands sujets de société de manière très
ouverte je pense que je reviens de deux
minutes sur les municipales on a vu le
réflexe très partisan qui revenue très
rapidement même dans les nouveaux partis
et pourquoi pas cher marche pour pour
les sites et reno mais je pense que ça
on l'a toujours évité et et pour ça on
doit faire valoir notre liberté notre
liberté de ton et notre liberté d coûte
et en effet je pense qu'on peut
progresser sur la démocratie
participative hostens plutôt mois de
cadre du grand débat où il n'y a pas ces
histoires de tirage au sort mais parce
qu'on est enraciné qu'on est partout où
laurens jan
oui moi je pense ça la question ça me
rappelle le bouquin succès qu'avait fait
stéphane hessel qui disait indignez vous
et je crois que le fond il est là ce qui
frappe dès janvier nous rejoignent
rejoindre des partis politiques c'est
qu'il ya un moment donné
itron font écho à leur indignation et et
puisque c'est un peu mon engagement
personnel je peux vous dire que sur les
questions d'environnement aujourd'hui il
ya des indignations très forte et relayé
porté porté ses indignations sur les
dégradations de la planète notamment
vis-à-vis des jeunes générations mais
tant que je pense aussi aux jeunes
parents qui s'inquiètent pour le devenir
de leurs enfants
on relira la d indignation et en
remobilisera parce que l'engagement
politique c'est quelque chose de très
pâle et si on joue pas sur les tripes
sont nés trop un petit peu à la surface
des choses généralistes ne mobilisera
pas et les gens ils ont envie
aujourd'hui de se mobiliser sur des
choses qui les indigne et c'est ça qu'il
faut qu'on relève
merci beaucoup yann richard moi
simplement pour pour vous dire que on y
arrivera par un alliage qui est celui du
cerveau et des tripes c'est à dire que
on doit mélanger ces deux ce jus de
cerveau et j'ai envie de dire ce même
cette sueur que chacun doit avoir et on
y arrivera sans opposer la réflexion qui
était notre parti qui était aussi à
partie d'intellectuels avec la vis et
khalid et mais si on ne veut que
conceptualiser comme un think tank
intellectuellement la société on va
échouer et donc le modèle doit être
l'alliage entre le cerveau et les tripes
merci beaucoup rice a écouté je crois
que chacun a eu une belle image de
conclusion merci beaucoup nathalie
laurence yann richard erwan merci
beaucoup pour cette première table ronde
et maintenant on se retrouve pour les
tables rondes en début d'après midi mais
je crois que tout de suite on a une
vidéo une message vidéo de bruno le
maire